this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman don't be
near things that could swallow you whole
ego like your jaws fixation come back
there was a moment I thought about that
where I was like I was raised on jaws
now stop it
yeah 1975 stop it
I was 5 years old I see that movie I
live in a beach town [ __ ] and I
forever stay yes that movie changed my
life and then some people my wife is
like well Steven Spielberg ruined you
and I was like no Steven Spielberg
ruined hook Steven Spielberg well
there's another guy you'll never work
with if anyone's listening to the show
who knows Steven please don't know I
would still like to work with this did
you like were you a hook fan I did like
hook yeah don't just say that he's gonna
work hey dude pottery or viscera or
bubble ooh or whatever they said in that
movie
bangarang that's it
[Music]
I haven't seen this real ugly first up
feel like I'm a big fan [ __ ]
smoochy pooches the audience like bang
wrangle oh yeah whatever
now's the time I had a hard hard Julia
Roberts thing I had a fixation oh and
she's late Tinkerbell
so I was I was a little with the pixie
her I was enamored by her in that film
yeah so I haven't seen it since I got
over that maybe I would look at it
differently now
I saw a hook recently when they called
it Christopher Robin how dare you how
dare you it's home it's the same [ __ ]
movie I don't think I don't I'm not
being shitty and I loved Christopher
Robin I wept during it and talked about
how much I loved it but it's they hooked
Christopher Robin essentially they were
like he forgot about who and grew up and
became a boring-ass adult and then also
who comes back into his life
and II or and Tigger and all the [ __ ]
rest and [ __ ] and he's like I'm a young
man again you learned something I forget
to tell you enjoyed it no I
wonderfully but it's annoying little
children in Christopher Robin yes well
it was just one yeah what we need to do
is figure out a [ __ ] hook we got a
hook something like figure out some [ __ ]
from in the past that people like you
know like here take a kid character that
grew up and then yes here's my pitch
we'll never get it okay and shoot the
moon absolutely Calvin and Hobbes right
Calvin grows up and he forgot that he
had a best friend was a tiger and then
Hobbes comes bad and eats him yeah yeah
it's a real tiger in the east Calvin
that maybe snorts yeah but like eats
people around Calvin and people think
Calvin's a serial killer but he's like
its Hobbes and then the whole time you
don't even know at the end of the movies
in a cell by himself and [ __ ] like that
and then a ghostly [ __ ] Hobbs is like
we'll get out of here soon count 11
maybe that's not the right idea for that
the Kevin Smith take on one of those
movies that's not quite hooking it
that's more [ __ ] killing it like if
you did the version where Calvin had
become like a Wall Street [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and then Hobbs comes you know leaps
on them and [ __ ] they go Vaughn sleds
and like all the [ __ ] they used to do
okay and then he you know [ __ ] awakens
the boy and Calvin pees on somebody's
windshield like you always see in those
windshields and pickup trucks when
you're in traffic well thank you for
finally writing with there yeah that's a
good idea
[Music]
you
[Music]